[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
baby you and Dawn are leaving are you
it isn't like what I think we better
than concern it but we got a wonderful
time thank you so much that's the
trouble with going steady with a girl
like Betty mr. mother always expect
their home by 11:00
[Music]
[Music]
and a client tonight
[Music]
not I've never felt about under windows
for the way I feel about you guys ready
I think you're wonderful too
hey you better watch it up wrong side of
the road little opera with you minute I
have to be on my lesson remember are you
sure you have to be home right away
[Music]
oh I guess not not for a while anyway
[Music]
[Music]
very
let's go hold on okay
[Music]
hey dawn boy what's the matter it looks
like you got deep trust I was just
thinking about something maybe that's
all thank you still dreaming about the
little Queen over the city late again
she's ready finds you a change man
you've come off that right now this is
Betty's not that kind of girl you
remember it okay okay just forget I
mentioned it
silently
you know those girls in city together
night yeah think they might have had
something you bet they did
oh oh you mean now I just forget about
it buddy they're just a couple of good
cakes you want to have a little fun oh I
don't know Mickey something happened
what do you mean something happen well I
picked some sort of sword down there
well don't worry about it it's probably
just a pimple or something the same
thing happened to me in it he cleared up
all by itself
oh man Davis I think I ought to go see
our doctor just to be sure
well suit yourself personally I just
forget all about it
[Music]
Wow they are take a look at this
something bad dr. Kaufman ordered it
well there's no doubt about what it is
those are the corkscrews things are the
germs of syphilis
PEPFAR doctor I now take it easy it
isn't the end of the world for you we
can cure syphilis especially if we find
it in the early stages such as yours are
you sure it's simple effective but
darkfield examination is proof enough
we'll also run a blood test on you
before you leave I don't know I don't
know how I got it I haven't done
anything done let's be straightforward
about this I'm not here to make a moral
judgment but you and I know that it was
contracted through sexual intercourse
with an infected person oh well I heard
you could get something like this from
Uncle toilet seat or something about as
much chance as being hit by a medium
what am I going to tell my dad the best
thing is they're telling the truth I'll
talk to him if you want me to then what
some things you should know about this
disease of yours now here we are this is
the store you have done it's called a
shaker
it is usually painless sometimes it
looks like this and sometimes like this
when one of these appears on or around
your sexual organs you probably got what
we call primary syphilis or pretty awful
looking well actually the appearance of
a chancre is very unfortunate
sometimes this or does not appear or
it's so small that you wouldn't notice
it and when that happens the disease
might go unnoticed for years
well what happened if you don't sign it
right away well the results can be
tragic in many instances syphilis can
[ __ ] you blind you destroy your brain
of course are very kill you eventually
you did say it could be cured though
especially in an early case like mine
yes in the stage you have we can knock
out the spider canary
by Ricky what's that well that's the
courts true shape thing that you saw on
a microscope like this these genes enter
the body when you have sexual
intercourse they burrow into the skin
usually causing a chancre to appear
where they headed they what they're
wearing into the bloodstream and the
shaker on the skin disappears now that
happens to quite a few people who think
they're all right after the sore clears
up then I'll have to have the names of
the girls you had sexual relations with
and naturally this is confidential but I
haven't exactly been buzzin as a matter
of fact I know exactly where I got it
there is this one girl over the city
Barbra Myers
will not tell me everything you can
about this girl down
it's either help Department over there
will want to contact you to see that
she's examined and treated before she
gives a disease to someone else I'm
afraid I don't know address
matter of fact I'm not even sure that's
a real name anybody else done lizard
just that one girl are you being honest
with me done I told you those this one
girl over in the city that's it now look
here son I've admired your courage for
coming in here and facing up to the
facts we can get it through your head
that you're dealing with a deadly
disease not some common cold or a case
of the chickenpox if you think you're
doing some girl a favor by protecting
our good name and reputation you're
wrong you're terribly wrong I said all
there is the safe there is no other girl
all right if there's no other girl we'll
leave it at that
but before we do I want to show you
something they come here I've showed you
the symptoms of syphilis as they appear
in the mail
generally the chancre appears on or
around the external sex organ
men and boys of contract settlers have a
good chance of spotting it when the
danger signal appears with a girl Oliver
it's not quite as easy you see a girl
could develop a chancre way up inside
like this I never know that she had
syllabus of course if she's lucky it'll
appear out in the open like this now we
don't have to worry about this do we Don
you say there's no other girl who might
have become infected by you even if a
girl had it and didn't know it she'd
find out wouldn't she
I mean that the other side yeah yeah
sometimes are the signs in a secondary
stage a few weeks or months after the
primary Schanke disappears she may
develop a sore throat patches of her
hair may come out or her skin may break
out no rash like this then again the
symptoms of secondary syphilis may be so
slight that they go unnoticed if she
doesn't go to a doctor if a doctor isn't
looking for syphilis it may never be
detected you see the secondary symptoms
like a primary she gave also will
disappear even was on treatment well
you'd fight it for sure when you had a
blood test before you got married they
discover it there and that would be a
lovely wedding present for a girl the
discover that she had syphilis a few
days before the wedding and in some
states people can get married even
without a blood test but suppose she had
undetected syphilis inactive in my
latest stages she might go for years
thinking that she's all right then
before she knows what's happening to her
she goes insane it becomes a hopeless
[ __ ] here's something else done
congenital syphilis look at this baby
its mother infected it before it was
born because she had syphilis and didn't
get treated and you say there is no
other girl done but if you're learning
to protect a girl just consider what it
might cost but she might not even have
it you can't take that risk only a
doctor can tell you for sure
she's a nice girl doctor I don't want to
have to go through all this if she
doesn't have to all right done it's your
decision but if you're the young man I
think you are you'll bring that girl in
to see me I have to think about it
doctor I've got to have time to think
about it
[Music]
might not even happen all he had doctor
himself you can't take that risk
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
she'll never know until it's too late
she goes insane or becomes a horrible
[Music]
[Music]
now there's something I want to tell
both of you now what's happened is past
you both have a disease and you will
both have to be treated then you took a
risk by doing something that society
condemns perhaps you didn't realize some
of the penalties involved - Teddy I know
that you blame done but you're just
thanking for one thing what thing doctor
so I thank you for giving it to me
Oh for adding me to enlist some girls so
what do I thank him for with gosh thanks
buddy I didn't mean to do this to you
and what is it doctor what do I thank
John for just be thankful he brought you
in in the first place
and these thankful he brought you before
it was too late
and we cut this thing in time we can
take care of it
you and Don are both going to be all
right you may be right doctor but right
now I'd rather be dead I know but you're
thinking only of this moment tomorrow
you'd rather be cured
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you
[Music]